[Music]
you need to be
careful with your plan yeah sorry i'll
go wait wait let me so i always advocate
that men need to have discipline yeah
but at the same time
a man can just walk up and leave so
which means that regardless of whether
you want to be a principal man or not
you don't have to be you're doing that
because it's morally right yeah so but
for you as a woman
your consequences are stuck if you go
through postnatal depression your body
changes you're not stuck with a baby no
no you have no consequence if you don't
want one you can get an abortion yeah
and if you if you get pregnant if you
get if you get if you get i hate that
argument if you get pregnant now if you
get pregnant it's a choice you you made
that you made because two people had
that choice though i think i think okay
okay
you have you have an iud you get an iud
what percent chance do you have of
getting pregnant and don't don't please
don't bring up the exception it's going
to irritate me
an iud
a coil what percent chance do you have
of getting pregnant
obviously
yeah it's very nice less than one
percent so if you choose to sleep with
men that would be poor fathers
like that that was a choice okay so you
made that first choice and then let's
say you do that and you get pregnant
yeah you can get an abortion but i'm
talking about what about the man that
decided to have sex with a woman without
a condom does he not have any
responsibility to the child
the woman is in charge of birth yeah so
if a woman gets pregnant she gets to
decide if she gives birth if i get
pregnant with a guy and i don't want to
have the kid and he and he's begging me
not to get an abortion he has no say
yes yeah so what i'm saying because of
that
women are in charge of birth yeah but
before that but the point that i was
making was that choice that they have is
not as simple as i'm just going to have
an abortion because that's their body
okay but not that but it wasn't it was
there are mental ramifications for doing
right i agree physical ramifications she
may just be like i can't do it but what
i'm saying is it's a layer of choices so
the girl could get an iud she could also
be on the list
so she could also wait so she could get
an iud she could also be on the pill
she could also get a plan b
she could also require that the men she
sleeps with wear a condom yeah and
and she if and if that doesn't work out
she can get an abortion so there are
five layers that she can pick where the
men only have one and the condom can get
stolen or it can break so the women have
five layers of protection the men have
one
therefore there is more responsibility
on the women if you get pregnant that
was a choice and it wasn't just one
choice it was five choices but also
women who have a lot of girls will have
sex with a man who they know doesn't
want to be a dad and still keep their
child which is fair enough because they
know they're going to get money bro but
if you don't want to be a dad should you
not be like i'm going to wear a condom
but this is what i'm saying but this is
why you just said it was fair enough
that you just lifted but that's what i
said one of them have really hormonal
effects on a woman and a condom doesn't
so for the man to just put on a condom
you're 100 right but i know a lot of
girls that say oh i don't i don't like
that's when men wear conditioners i have
a question for the men i have a question
for the men what percentage of girls
make you wear condoms
[Music]
um
i make myself wait okay okay but
if it wasn't up to you let's say
a lot of women okay no let's say let's
say it was 100 up to the woman okay
what percent of women make you wear
condoms i'm gonna be real yeah most of
them like they don't say nothing to me
like i just draw for it they don't say
nothing to me they're happy to just do
whatever so they'll do whatever you say
what percent of girls
i don't even know to be honest
um
i don't know to be honest you know i
wouldn't say i don't think
[Music]
this guy's not dropping no no
you're not chopping bruh
that's doing this
hypothetically okay what about you guys
ten
ten percent i think
so the highest the highest percentage we
have right here is 20.
and these are these are five guys one in
five
yeah one that's not a high number so
should they not be taking accountability
for if they're going to reproduce
i'm just saying you should know about
that but the whole the whole point the
whole point is that a man can make a
choice okay he he could be super careful
like drake was and he could still get
the condom stolen i'm saying women have
five layers of choices they can make i
hate that and the point is that women
don't face consequences for bad
decisions for example they can steal the
condom and that's not illegal
yeah
yeah but yeah if you put a hole in the
condom you're going to be yeah yeah
you're still finished yeah there's whole
reddit threads of girls trying to get
pregnant by their boyfriends
yeah and so if we go back
like how many of
that is taking place two
you actually just looking after your
penis and putting on a condom if you do
not want okay but what if what if if she
if she pokes holes in the condom
and what but also there's certain women
that i've said to me
there's certain girls that have said to
me they don't like condoms they're not
like but
i didn't want to have a child with her
then i would be like i am not sleeping
with you yeah
no but i'm saying so if
we have five layers of account how can
you not say it's more on the women when
i just listed five layers of
accountability the man can do one it
could break right and then he has no
control over anything yeah and then it
would go into the woman right but i'm
saying it's how can you not say it's
more on the women when i just listed
five different ways i didn't i didn't go
into [ __ ] i said it's both people have
a responsibility when you're having sex
that after this if a pregnancy occurs
and a baby comes along that you are
accountable for bringing up that child i
would say i would say it's like 80 90 on
the woman because she has five layers of
accountability the dude has one the
weight and
we control we control access to sex men
control access to relationships
we we get to pick who who goes inside of
us so if you're not picking good men
like i don't feel bad for you if you end
up a single mom but then that could be
the same for the guy though so if you're
left with a baby mother that is now
taking all of your money should you not
have been accountable for not buttons
i do feel bad for them because i don't
think that's fair i think you should
face the consequences of your actions
most men want to take care of their kids
but also the problem with
your stance is the fact that even if i
want the child i can't keep it if i
don't want it i can't opt out of paying
for it yeah and so either way you lose
because the child was because
because the equal level of
accountability would be if women control
access to sex would be like if you get
pregnant your fault the equal
accountability for a man would be if you
pick the wrong woman and she does a
madness you have to take accountability
that you pick the wrong one and many
people do like oh vanessa [ __ ] and then
uh can i say that on here
finessing [ __ ] take the bag and then
run off yeah women are celebrated for
doing that done
big facts
that's what i'm saying you think women
are celebrating i don't know
i don't think about it
but here's the thing i don't think it's
equal because men face consequences
women don't they don't because the
consequences would be having to raise
their child on your own but most of the
time they're getting financial help and
that's what she's saying they're still
like my man said about the glass seed
and then um
the cushion bro they've always got a
cushion that